[Music]  Janet Jackson receives the icon award at  the 2018 Billboard Music Awards I'm  deeply humbled and grateful for this  award the 52 year old singer has been a  pop icon since the 80s with hits like  Rhythm Nation that's the way love goes  all for you and many more on Sunday  night the pop legend was honored with  the prestigious award which recognizes  artists extraordinary contributions to  music Bruno Mars made a surprise  appearance presenting Janet with the  icon award she is the seventh artist and  first black woman to receive it at long  last women have made it clear that we  will no longer be controlled manipulated  or abused I stand with those women  Janet not only accepted the award she  shut it down with a medley of her hits  nasty and throbs  in her first performance on television  in nearly a decade  [Music]  [Applause]